[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti sono veramente fiero
di essere qui in questo palco che da
ragazzino ricordavo via del campana
quando sono cresciuto quando i miei
genitori mi hanno portato dalla sicilia
e quindi mi sono innamorato di questo
posto e non l'ho mai mollato nonostante
tutto sia andato sempre in giro per il
mondo in giro per il mondo ovunque
dall'asia dall'america
chiaramente la mia ombra mia ombra e
perché la mia vita 40 anni che indosso
questa giacca e l'ho voluta mettere qui
per tutti voi per ricordarvi che un
lavoro che cambio con
tantissime soddisfazioni umano antico da
oltre insegno ma ampio anno questa cosa
di una mattina mi sveglio e sono fiero
di andare nelle mie cugine ad
abbracciare nei ragazzi a divulgare
quella che è la mia passione è vero che
ha un lavoro faticoso non è facile però
pian piano le soddisfazioni sono
arrivate le stelle e forchette i
punteggi nelle guide e quant'altro tante
riviste tante soddisfazioni consulente
internazionale quindi essere qui nel
paese dove appunto nelle 82 è nato il
ristorante arnolfo e
grande onore pensate che ho avuto un
sacco di offerte per spostarmi a firenze
a pechino in cina però
il mio cuore resta quando mi
sono legato a questo territorio
perché è un territorio bello magico
perché una piccola cosa che va oltre
io sono molto contento perché da tutto
il mondo vengano circa 6 mila persone
ogni anno
armi e cerco di salutarli tutti
bene è vero che questo questo lavoro è
un lavoro faticoso e vero che non è una
cosa molto molto facile però io dico
a voi perché si va meno ristorante
stellato del ristorante stellato è
sinonimo di costi folli è sinonimo di
non si mangia si esce fuori dal
ristorante ma insomma devo andarmi a
mangiare un panino da pollo no non è
così non è così ve lo dico ve lo
garantisco perché
a me è sempre piaciuto questa cosa di
ringraziare l'ospite il cliente che fa
il viaggio quindi gratificarlo per il
viaggio che fa anche se sì se è un
cittadino di colle val mesi io amo
gratificare gli e clienti per questo
motivo
quando ero ragazzo pensate
dopo la scuola alberghiera non è che
avessi fatto un po di gavetta rimini al
grand hotel ho visto un sacco di i
movimenti però poi ho fatto un master a
saint moritz
con i miei primi risparmi sono il sogno
era quello che gli anni ottanta
chiaramente la cucina non era così
all'avanguardia in italia di conseguenza
avevamo un problema serio cioè c'era il
cambio generazionale
e quindi la voglia di portare avanti dei
progetti nuovi senza tralasciare
chiaramente la nostre tradizioni e o se
tradizioni sono fondamentali nostra
storia è tutto
e allora nessuno era quello di andare a
conosci mont d'or vicino lione che c'era
un grande chef francese
paul bocuse è mancato da un paio di anni
se vado lì con un amico ma proviamo a
pranzo perché a pranzo i pranzi erano in
francia leggermente più meno costosi
rispetto alla cena quindi non dico che
avevo i franchi francesi conta di mason
ma ero abbastanza
preciso e ci accolse appunto paul bocuse
e ci dette ci offrite di pianti extra
perché il nostro menù era quello di
pranzo o più ridotto e pian piano ho
apprezzato questo gesto
che sarebbe bene
dedicarsi un po ai giovani mi sono tutta
la vita dedicato ai giovani o formato
più di
centinaia di ragazzi una cinquantina di
loro hanno il loro ristorante qualcuno
ha già il ristorante stellato quindi
insomma è una bella cosa una bella
sinergia quindi io dico investite anche
su un ristorante stellato perché basta
uscire due o tre volte in meno nella
trattoria o pizzeria vicino casa e per
l'esperienza io dico una due volte
l'anno vale la pena ve lo garantisco
perché la mia il mio lavoro è una
passione da
40 anni e una passione che porto avanti
e porta avanti con zero spreco
porto avanti con l'educazione e la
ricerca quindi il mio territorio voglio
voglio si che i miei menu sono composti
dal dai prodotti nel mio territorio meno
possibile sprechi e soprattutto anche
viaggi lunghi insomma cercare di usare
il territorio toscano perché ha
la collina la montagna e mare quindi
fare un menu vegetariano un menù di
pesce o di carne c'è tutta la bella cosa
fare educazione e anche portando fuori i
miei ragazzi facendoli conoscere le
realtà portati nel valdarno
proprio questa fine stata e da una
produttrice locale che laura per i che
alleva appunto animali da cortile in
modo vero quindi per fare su un pollo ci
mette circa sette mesi quindi insomma
c'è un lavoro minuzioso quindi far
toccare con mano questo questo tipo di
realtà che poi diventa un architettura
nel piatto l'architettura che si consuma
tutti i giorni e io me la posso
riproporre ogni servizio a pranzo ea
cena e prima di tutto mi voglio
emozionare io quando faccio qualcosa e
trasmettere queste emozioni a tutti voi
questo è il concetto e trasmettono a
miei ragazzi che senza stancarmi senza
andare
avanti proprio perché oggi c'è bisogno
di nuovi stimoli
i giovani hanno bisogno di stimoli e per
questo che sto creando un nuovo progetto
il progetto e mi sta dando grandi
soddisfazioni
soprattutto perché ho voluto coinvolgere
tutti gli artigiani locali nel mio
territorio
quindi dal giallo di siena della
montagnola senese qui a due passi al
travertino di rapolano e tante altre
situazioni che scoprirete se venite a
trovarmi perché è una cosa ogni volta
che vado in cantiere e ormai veramente
siamo agli sgoccioli e qualcosa di
emozionante e oggi noi abbiamo bisogno
di emozioni
perché il movimento diciamo
ambizioso è quello di stimolarci di più
i punti della vita sono tanti e chiaro
che noi abbiamo bisogno
non solo del lavoro ne abbiamo parlato
le nostre ombre sono i nostro tempo
libero la famiglia e il lavoro
io dvd ray questi tre opzioni
il 33 per cento per ogni tipologia di
cose quindi il lavoro al 33 per cento il
tempo libero per noi stessi e il 33 per
cento e il resto per la famiglia questo
è il punto principale cardine della vita
e bisogna essere felici di vivere perché
siamo tutti in transito
e questo transito
lungo il bosco raccogliere i frutti
migliori di questa nostra vita perché
sennò non si va da nessuna parte quindi
creassi stimoli nuove cose la con realtà
anche tra amici
creare non sono una ricetta invitare gli
amici e stappare una bottiglia di
champagne e creare magari
una cena semplice a casa con prodotti
però di qualità con prodotti del nostro
territorio
questo è fondamentale
sinistra diale lo champagne e orti che
si fanno ma abbiamo la chianina abbiamo
la cinta senese abbiamo un sacco di
prodotti da valorizzare stagione per
stagione quindi è giusto che ci sia
questo è fondamentale non correte con i
carrelli a fare la spesa e poi li
congelate il prodotto invece no bisogna
prendere il prodotto fresco prodotto
nostro artigianale dai contadini locali
aiutiamo la nostra minotti piccoli
produttori
23 21 e fanno con amore questi prodotti
e io ogni giorno condivido queste cose
con piccoli produttori facendo
dal mare mi chiamano abbiamo pescato un
branzino
oppure il fracasso e del casentino mi fa
lunedì sochaux 2 capretti fan favolosi
che fai
il portale a macello è ecco questa è la
differenza
del nutrirsi e di emozionarsi per
nutrirsi questo è il mio è mio
dire divulgare divulgare il buono e il
bello della vita a soprattutto delle
nuove leve delle nuove generazioni
perché possano portare avanti queste
emozioni a tutti voi
al noto territorio nazionale guardate
che il brand tuscany brand toscana nel
mondo e il numero uno e se io ho scelto
di rimanere a colle val d'elsa e perché
siamo nel cuore della toscana
questo punto e arrivano da tutto il
mondo
comunque diciamo che c'è una situazione
molto interessante
legata a
all'architettura e alla cucina
arnolfo
ho studiato tutta la sua storia ho visto
il museo dell'opera del duomo a firenze
e sono appassionato di queste situazioni
ma giro anche il guggenheim museum di
bilbao o degli stati uniti di new york
perché è tutto il movimento quindi dalla
storia si va a una storia nuova
una storia da raccontare da portare
avanti questo è il punto principale
progetti progetti progetti e sempre la
vita è piena di progetti mai fermarsi e
la linfa per andare avanti
grazie a tutti
[Musica]